should you brush wet hair I used to
think this was a blanket no but it
actually depends when your hair is wet
the water breaks some of the bones
gluing the inside of your hair together
it also raises the cuticle scale so they
can bash against each other more and
Chip so wet hair is overall more fragile
it also sticks hairs together so you
need to use more Force to separate them
that's why brushing wet hair is really
damaging if your hair is straight but it
can actually be the opposite if your
hair is Curly all of this still happens
but two big differences one curly hairs
stick to each other less because they
tessellate less it's like how spaghetti
sticks together much more than instant
noodles weakening the bonds makes the
curls loosen and geometrically that
means there's less chance of tangling
which in itself causes a lot of damage
and breakage and these two effects can
offset the downsides of brushing wet
hair so overall there can be less damage